I would like to make a distinction in
say between age zero to about 15 or 16
years before I was,
before I came in touch with a woman
called,
we called [inaudible] in my secondary
school in Kenya.
And the time after that,
um,
before I met sister as is
the Islam of my family was not
political.
So I don't,
I do not remember either my father or my
mother saying that a society has to be,
um,
as you know,
sharia should be the rule of a,
of a country or a society with one
exception.
In the one year that we were in Saudi
Arabia,
there was no distinction between a
secular sphere and,
uh,
and,
and you know,
let's say the film of series a in the
form of,
of God,
these white intertwined in Islam.
And in the one year that we were in
Saudi Arabia,
we lived according to Sharia and the
state was run through Islamic law.
So the beheadings,
for instance,
amputations every Friday,
the stonings,
that kind of thing that happened.
And there was a distinction,
um,
when atrocities in Somalia were carried
out by a secular dictatorships that has,
such as Muhammad [inaudible],
my mother would denounce,
condemn those atrocities.
But when atrocities were carried out in
the state of Saudi Arabia,
thieves who are amputated,
people's heads were cut off.
That was sharia law.
And that was something that the victim
deserved because he violated the law of
God.
But we left that behind us in when we
left Saudi Arabia and went into
Ethiopia.
My life in Ethiopian,
in Kenya until my 16th year was I would
just see,
you know,
praying five times a day.
It was very,
of Islam was there socially and
culturally it wasn't a political issue.
When I meet in 1985 sisters is a
different kind of,
Islam is introduced and different
meaning also from the one I knew from my
family,
it was a political Islam.
It was very clear.
It was an individual choice.
It was about what she referred to as the
inner she had struggling to simply to
meet the obligations to make sure that
you play five times instead of three
times or two times.
Um,
fast,
all of the Ramadan days,
all 30 of them,
not half a day I say used to do or a
week in a month or something like that.
It's just adhering to the rules every
day.
The rules that allow that have permitted
and trying to abstain from what's
Harambe or what is forbidden.
This is reinforced within the Somali
community because Kenya is a very
multicultural place and societies it was
not as Somali but in the Somali space
they were fingers like this man we call
it buffalo song.
He will fast for a hundred days and he
introduced the same kind of radical
political all consuming Islam that
divides the world into we and they and
the division started within the Islamic
community so we were those of us who
followed the foods rigidly.
Those other Muslims who are neglectful
of the rules were considered to be non
Muslims hypocrites.
We had all sorts of negative attributes
for them and then that they extended to
the non Muslims.
My grandmother represented what's we
generally generally would call
traditional nomadic Somali life and the
values of that tradition,
mainly tribal,
very much we oriented clan oriented.
She taught me my blood line because that
is your,
you know,
you cannot survive without your
bloodline.
Um,
she taught us all these anecdotes about
how to survive in the desert,
which animals to fear which animals are
not to fear which animals to hunt and
eat.
Um,
she was very superstitious when I got
ill or my sister got ill,
she had no access or knowledge of modern
medicine.
So she dealt with the challenges in life
with the seasons,
with droughts.
And then she had superstitious
explanations for it.
She was a Muslim,
but a very different Muslim than for
instance,
sees as the sisters Caesar,
how Islam was very much diluted with her
own cultural,
um,
traditional superstitions.
Um,
for instance,
she thought it was a good thing to
celebrate the birthday of the Prophet
Muhammad.
Uh,
which later at sisters isn't vocal song
would say that was a bad thing to do.
Um,
she could not read the Koran.
She had land a few verses by heart.
Just enough to pray.
But she didn't allow us to put the
Qur'an on the ground.
She would make us kiss the Qur'an and
puts it on her the highest surface and
faster cleaner has before we touch the
time,
anything like that.
So she was just more of a traditional
Somali nomadic
value system.
With respect to Islam.
We should make a distinction between
Muslims and Islam.
Muslims as individual human beings like
you and me can be influenced.
We're not born.
It's not a genetic discrepancy to be a
Muslim.
You are just an individual human being
and you can be persuaded to change your
mind.
And so engage in critical thinking and
change the course of your life is alarm.
Just like Nazis.
Him today is a very violent
totalitarian,
the dangerous doctrine.
And the sooner we see it,
the better.
It depends on where they are.
If you are in Europe or in America,
you'll have access to so much education,
so much empirical evidence that you can
change your own life if you do certain
things.
I would say to Muslims living in the
West,
take advantage,
fully advantage of that.
Um,
develop your mind and your faculties of
critical thinking and look around you
and why are we here?
I'm in Cheyenne answered that question.
What I'm millions of Muslims leaving
their own home countries and seeking a
better life in the west.
What is it in the West that they're
doing great but we are doing wrong if
you are in Muslim countries than there
is a difference that a welcome Muslim
countries through oil,
solely citizens,
United Arab Emirates,
Kuwait and so on who can afford because
they don't have to go about it.
Didn't have to spend 90% of their time
seeking brad like the poor neighborhoods
of Egypt.
Uh,
that group can make a change and can
bring in because we live in the age of
Internet and so on.
They can't translate progressive books,
the Enlightenment Command lots of ideas,
books here into Arabic and bring it and
give it to their own people.
Right now,
the only reading the Koran,
it's,
it's very little to live on
intellectually,
um,
for in poor countries.
Um,
what you see now is that the Islamic
Brotherhood or Brotherhood
organizations,
fundamentalist Islamic organizations are
the ones who are providing the care.
And it's an uncorrupted care,
health care,
you know,
food.
Making sure that places are safe,
neighborhoods are safe and so on.
And that's can be challenged by,
I would say,
people who will not replace one form of
oppression with another form of
oppression.
Yeah.